[Music]
do maps lie we all know the phrase lies
Dam lies and statistics and we know that
data can be used and abused but what
about Maps can they be weapons of
deception or tools of tyranny of course
they can Maps can mislead due to honest
Mistakes by the author or they can
mislead us on purpose let's take as an
example the issue of mapping house
prices in London many would argue prices
are far too high but do the maps agree
as an example let's look at two
different maps of London house prices
both Maps use the same data but with
very different results Jim wants to show
that things aren't actually that bad and
that prices aren't that high in this
case he could use an equal interval
classification like in this map where
prices don't look too high in most of
the city most areas show an average
house price in the lowest statistical
category this helps make the argument
that prices aren't actually that high
but Anna wants to show how outof control
prices are in London compared to the
rest of the country so she's made a map
which shows areas of London which have
an average house price below the UK
average and areas which are above the
national average as we can see this
makes London look very expensive and
this more closely fits the national
narrative on the topic but neither of
these examples are 100% correct though
the second one is perhaps much more
powerful even though it uses the same
data as the first if we wanted to
produce something more meaningful which
represented the underlying data in a
more conventional way a map like this
would be more
useful so do maps lie well kind of they
can be designed to deliberately mislead
us or influence us one way or another
about a particular issue and this is the
point Maps aren't neutral map makers can
lie it always helps to look at a map
with a critical eye next time you look
at a map ask yourself the following
questions before deciding what it shows
who made it why did they make it what
does it actually tell us
[Music]